[Musique]
moi oui je la suis ou pas ouais va être
magnifique celle-ci cette vidéo où voilà
c'est dit
allez nous faut aussi un angoisse big
flo libye j'ai fait la beauté rien ça
c'est très important
nous on est dans les cages les couples
ont dû casser tous les deux depuis
plusieurs années on est plus à jean
michel c'est pas très dur en même temps
et c'est plus facile qu'avant moi ça me
laisse un peu la surenchère des réseaux
sociaux être toujours beaucoup de
critiques sur les réseaux surtout je
parle pas de nous mais des fois y'a des
trucs super bien qui se passe et les
gens viennent critiquer à chaque fois ça
va être un peu trop négatif à favoriser
la sueur critique pour le buzz cherche
le buzz sans vraiment il se prend pour
la parole de dieu
[Musique]
l'album alors il ya un album qui est
super cool que j'avais découvert un
premier temps s'appelle la vraie vie
c'est l'album de big flo et oli
ils sont déjà là double platine c'est
vrai quoi ils sont double platine et du
coup franchement je vous le conseille à
frontalement